un homme dans l'obscurité
une petite pièce aménagée pour
l'occasion dans la pénombre on distingue
un immense microphone une voix qui
résonne qui parlent de manière invisible
et qui par la voie des ondes sait déjà
qu'elle va bouleverser des milliers
d'âmes à des milliers de kilomètres à la
ronde
cette voix c'est celle du général de
gaulle pendant la dernière guerre
mondiale
mais c'est aussi celle d'orson welles en
1938 il parle à la radio il est en train
d'inaugurer la première pièce
radiophonique il raconte aux américains
que les martiens attaque c'est la
panique en amérique en cours dans les
rues on se cloîtrent chez soi
quel pouvoir celui de la radio cette
radio elle est arrivée en amérique
vraiment dans la fin des années 20 et
avec elle l a amené un objet magnifique
le microphone quelle histoire
le microphone les premiers speaker
découvre se découvre un pouvoir
incommensurable
les chanteurs de l'époque chantait sans
microphone
il chantait avec un porte-voix soit
avec le microphone soignies iloveyou la
radio un pouvoir extraordinaire qui
allait bouleverser la terre entier
beaucoup de français n'acceptent pas la
capitulation ni la servitude
[Musique]
madame
je pourrais continuer les speakers les
chanteurs de radio qu'on appelle les
crooners se découvre un pouvoir
extraordinaire vous vous rendez vous
rendre des comptes
mesdemoiselles imaginez vous vous êtes
dans la fin des années 20 bonsoir
mademoiselle je suis la voix qui parle
je suis la voix qui chante ou les deux
peut être
je suis près de vous très proche de vous
je pourrais même si vous le voulez me
glisser dans votre lit car je suis votre
ami la radio pourtant n'est pas
intrusive elle est merveilleuse et
l'accompagnent elle informe elle combat
la solitude elle charme elle s'imposera
dans le monde entier dans les années 60
elle est au sommet les gamins ont des
petits postes à transistor il seul col à
l'oreille et planqué au fond de leur lit
le soir ils écoutent salut les copains
ils écoutent europe 1 il écoute le rock
and roll le twist beaucoup plus rigolo
petits lots rossi et dalida dans les
années 80 souvenez-vous pour certains
c'est une révolution
la radio subi sa deuxième évolution
l'afm le son stéréo
la golf gti de mon cousin toute la
carrosserie vibre avec michael jackson
grâce aux radios libres qui arrive et
elle arrive contre le pouvoir en place
parce que la guerre de monopole à qu'on
a commencé mais vous rendez compte
écouter de la musique américaine
gratuite alors que le vinyle coûte cher
c'est merveilleux la radio dans les
années 2000 la radio est toujours le
média préféré des français
mais de nouveaux dieux arrive il
s'appelle bill gates steve jobs ce sont
les visionnaires de l'internet est très
vite il faut en sorte que chacun d'entre
nous peut désormais construire ses
propres images ses propres vidéos
c'est l'avènement des youtuber alors
vite la télévision prend peur vous savez
la télévision de papa avec la l'antenne
sur le toit avec l'écran bombay
il faut vite la moderniser alors on l'a
fait passer au numérique
une belle image qualité numérique 1 sont
qualité hd ça s'appelle la tnt une
petite guerre de monopole au passage
parce que de nouvelles stations arrive
et ça c'est très embêtant pour le
monopole alors il faut vite faire de
même pour la radio parce qu'entre temps
steve et bil in ou créés les gars phares
les telcos et le danger c'est qu'il y
ait une radio unique radio amazon radio
google et plus cette diversité gratuite
magique anonymes non traçable alors vous
allez me dire mais pourquoi parler de
radio encore en 2020 alors qu'on a les
webradios on a les applis android iphone
et bien je vais vous rappeler quelque
chose en 2015
on est au stade de france souvenez-vous
l'attend tard une bombe on explose toute
l'année des attentats les gens sont
confinés dans le stade alors qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils saisissent leur radio
vous savez comme en 1968 pendant les
manifestations pour écouter ce qui se
passe pour écouter france info europe 1
le problème c'est qu'ils prennent leurs
smartphones et les telcos ont enlevé la
puce radio gratuite vous savez par la
voie des ondes invisibles et ils ont mis
la 3g la 4g est là quand il ya plus de
500 personnes comme ce soir qui font le
même geste qui écoutent la radio il ya
plus de bande passante et la radio elle
est silencieuse alors le gouvernement
s'est inquiété et dès 2009
on a essayé de lancer l'équivalent de la
tnt la radio numérique terrestre des
abbés plus les anglais appellent ça le
dab des habits plus digital audio
broadcasting - cette époque je suis à
france inter je m'éclate je suis
animateur et producteur ma première
émission de radio s'appelle crooner j'en
fais pleins d'autres en public et mes
anciens patrons me dise jean baptiste
vous allez réaliser le rêve de votre vie
vous allez créer crooner non pas
l'émission mais crooner la radio kronor
radio qui prête à rêver comme une
merveilleuse mise en abîme la voix de
nora jones qui
prend le relais de celle de frank
sinatra une écriture nu moore des
chroniques des informations c'est
formidable c'est un très beau projet le
sait ça me donne le tableau d'honneur
c'est la nouvelle radio qui va mettre en
avant la nouvelle norme technologique
des abbés plus un son de meilleure
qualité d image qui s'affichent sur les
écrans
c'est un bouleversement pour moi en 2011
et lâche ma radio va rester muette parce
que c'est la troisième guerre de
monopole les grands groupes privés ne
vole pas de nouvelles radios la guerre
va durer 10 en 2009 2019
en 2014 on démarre dans l'indifférence
générale à paris en 2016 le cssa contre
vents et marées nous donne de nouvelles
villes lille strasbourg lyon et en 2019
enfin la radio au crowne kroner radio ma
radio commence à faire même des
audiences à paris parce que les voitures
sont déjà équipés les équipements
arrivent dans les magasins mais en 2019
ça y est les grands groupes privés
abdique ils baissent la garde
ok on va démarrer le des abbés plus en
france le service public est très
heureux car monsieur restore le nouveau
ministre très inquiet de la situation
dit oui oui on va le faire très vite
c'est le début d'une belle aventure qui
commence
après 10 ans d'attentes mais quelle
belle aventure et surtout pour vous les
auditeurs des images sur les écrans un
son hd plein de radio nouvelles y
compris à limoges c'est une merveilleuse
aventure et ça va ressembler à ça
bonjour oui pour le coup c'est côté
crooner
vous
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs j'ai l'honneur et
le privilège de vous annoncer qu'en 2020
en octobre 2020 toutes vos grandes
stations préférées privés et publics
vont émettre sur la france comme vous le
voyez en son hd en des abbés plus avec
quelques images qui viendront illustrer
les propos une révolution 2020 c'est
également l'année du son de la
suprématie de l'audio
c'est l'année de l'explosion du podcast
partout dans le monde
vous savez les images qu'elles soient
numériques ou qu'elles soient anciennes
montre le monde heurté dans lequel nous
vivons
la radio elle elle a du sens
et elle a de l'imaginaire elle est
indispensable à nos vies et elle vient
de vivre sa troisième grande mutation
alors surtout quand vous achetez votre
nouveau récepteur radio sur votre
autoradio demandé bien l'option des
abbés plus pour écouter crooner radio et
le reste n'a que peu d'importance le
digital est un complément sur votre
smartphone iphone android sur vos applis
écoutait grunner radio sur le crooner
point fr mais n'oubliez jamais le sens
l'ubiquité la parole et je dirais même
mieux
au commencement était le verbe et en
2020 plus que jamais le verbe c'est la
radio
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]